boa noite
eu tinha preparado uma coisa que eu
mostrar alguns slides alguns vídeos mas
eu fiquei inspirado
inspirado por que eu acho que esse é o
motivo da gente está aqui
afinal quem é que tem um sonho eu digo
pra vocês
é importante a gente ter sonhos na
verdade toda a minha história para
chegar onde eu tô começou com um sonho
isso é de crianças e adolescentes um
besta né eu jogava muito jogo de
computador e aí jogava videogame queria
desenvolver jogos para desenvolver jogos
isso alguns anos atrás era ainda mais
difícil de se imaginar como uma
profissão no brasil
mas eu acreditei e chegou a fatídica
hora vou entrar na faculdade
vou entrar na faculdade poxa eu quero
fazer computação aí sabe as palavras de
meu pai
você vai fazer engenharia menino porque
engenharia do dinheiro você precisa
primeiro de dinheiro pra qualquer coisa
é bem ele me alimentava a gente não pode
negar muito né então eu falei pô vou ver
como é que é
mas aí me falar uma coisa sobre
engenharia que bateu forte que me deu
essa sensação me deu essa inspiração que
foi uma palavra
o engenheiro cria dinheiro cria ele pega
ciência e materializa da ciência alguma
coisa no mundo ele pega os estudos que
os matemáticos físicos
os cientistas estão fazendo a gente
tenta trazer isso pra realidade de uma
pessoa
então esse é a função de engenheiro foi
nossa eu gostei disso quero legal é
estudei bastante entrei na usc né
na verdade foi interessante que eu só
tinha visitado a usp uma vez e falei
nossa grande para a única coisa que
tinha noção
já entrei na usp foi nossa que legal
não sou mais inteligente porque meu deus
do céu quanta gente inteligente tinha eu
olhava do latin ncap
mas o que eu vejo as primeiras provas só
tomei nada mas falei não legal vamos lá
vou dar um duro vou estudar vou
continuar e continuei conseguir na época
eu entrava era mais generalista entrava
primeiro engenharia aí depois tinha que
escolher entre engenharia elétrica
engenharia civil mecânica
fui pra elétrica e depois da elétrica
computação 6 engenharia da computação
decorrer um curso cooperativo que era
doida que se fazia quatro meses de aula
quatro meses de estágio e decidi que eu
queria fazer diploma duplo mas isso só
pros caras que estudam muito e que é
isso bem basicamente no quarto anos aí
ficava dois anos fora e depois voltava
para o terminal na faculdade aqui tinha
dois diplomas
estudei muito entrei fiz iniciação
científica comecei a trabalhar
desenvolvendo em open gl que era
basicamente a coisa que precisava para
fazer jogos e queria descobrir um
laboratório que eu queria para a
alemanha
estudei alemão alemão não é fácil não é
fácil estudar alemão com assim mero de
melhorar minhas notas fiscais entrevista
de um programa não agora vai agora vai
estudar isso estudei
não foi daquela sensação do tipo poxa
estou me preparando já os dois anos mais
ou menos para isso não conseguir que
ruim mas vamos lá nem aí surge outra
oportunidade não vou para os estados
unidos
o raio é legal português da estudei não
foi
acho que eu tenho um problema mas surgiu
uma oportunidade que era para a itália
eu olhei eram os mesmos documentos para
ir para os estados unidos já tinha tudo
pronto falei pô eu não sei falar
italiano nunca estudei italiano
nem sei que eu vou fazer se for
pretamaria tentar né eu to aqui deu
certo
imagina a minha cara quando eu descobri
que eu tinha tipo três meses para
aprender italiano e ir para itália
estudar lá fora estava perdido
não sabia que eu ia fazer direito mas
fui fui e foi bom o cara morava numa
cidadezinha tranquila eu morava perto de
milão em como como é como cidade
turística
aprendi muito muito mais que isso
eu nunca ia esperar mas eu arranjei um
estágio para desenvolver jogos
foi sensacional
eu estava trabalhando com o playstation
3 xbox 360 uma coisa aqui no brasil era
extremamente raro e e aí veio essa idéia
é essa
esse sonho porque o que estão fazendo
aqui a gente não faz lá que eles têm que
a gente não tem gente pode ir além
a gente pode fazer mais esse sonho de
vamos desenvolver alguma coisa no brasil
voltei para o brasil um trabalho em
nenhuma duas empresas trabalham uma
startup de jogos que ficou enorme que
fazer aquele jogo esmagar a formiga no
celular provavelmente metade você já
jogaram sim é brasileiro e falei meu
eles fecharam estúdio e aí eu falei vou
abrir uma empresa
foi então que eu abrir uma empresa nem
que bom que games final tinha que seu
nome é divertido nessa gente vai fazer
alguma coisa divertida mas ainda assim
tinha falta de alguma coisa
foi quando me deparei com a tecnologia
de realidade virtual isso em 2013
alguém aqui já experimentou realidade
virtual legal né alguns de vocês eu não
sabia o quanto a gente já tinha avançado
nisso na interação o sensor de presença
que você sente com isso é impressionante
eu peguei um óculos rift coloquei na
cabeça ea única coisa que eu conseguia
pensar se vai mudar o mundo
eu consigo estar em outro lugar um lugar
que nem precisa ser de verdade
simplesmente de colocar um óculos na
cabeça
então a gente começou a pensar poxa
vamos fazer alguma coisa legal com isso
né eu
no caso eu tenho uma parceria muito
forte é que a minha esposa minha esposa
ela é uma visionária eu falo que na
verdade ela que deveria estar falando na
maioria das vezes quando eu falo ea
gente chegou à conclusão vamos fazer um
projeto vamos trazer de nos autos para a
realidade virtual e conversando com o
primo dela ele virou falou poxa mais
porque dinossauros em realidade virtual
porque te rex porque esses não só tenham
dinossauros brasileiros
eles foram atendidos ao brasileiro quem
aqui conhece algum dinossauro brasileiro
não tem um pessoal que legal
geralmente é muito menos viu seis são
cientistas mesmo porque a gente ficou
impressionado
todo mundo sabe que quem eu te rex
mas quem conhece o bis auro quem conhece
ou saturnália é muito raro então há mais
ou menos quatro anos a gente começou
essa corrida pra criar o dia do brasil
hoje no brasil foi uma iniciativa que
partiu desse sonho o sonho de trazer
alguma coisa de tecnologia que
mostrassem a realidade virtual de última
geração porque a gente cansou de ver
coisas que não eram aquilo que o
potencial nosso som
aqui no brasil a gente às vezes tensas
síndrome de vira lata e olhe falata
legalzinho mas não penso quanto pode ser
sensacional e aí a gente começou com um
sonho
vamos fazer de nós somos brasileiros e
como falar com o professor indicado não
professor aqui da geologia da usp hulu
professora daniele falando pra ele
nos apresentamos com currículo nem nada
então quando a gente conversou ele falou
olha eu acho muito legal a idéia de
vocês mas de aluno louco tudo bem eu
tenho não sei se vai rolar esse projeto
mas ele é um super apoio pra gente e foi
muito legal que depois se descobriu que
a gente tinha experiência internacional
desenvolvida muita coisa muito tempo e
conseguimos fazer um projeto lançado
pela lei ronê aí consegui uma lei rounet
depois de um ano porque foi o ano da
copa e demorou tanto aí falando legal
agora a gente foi aprovado na lei
rouanet eu achava que aprovou a lei
maneta beleza a gente podia captar
dinheiro das empresas
quem não vai querer investir num projeto
de realidade virtual de nos solos
brasileiros ea gente ainda tinha
conseguido o apoio do museu catavento
cultural
quem conhece museu catavento cultural
sabe que é um lugar sensacional é lindo
que não conhece pelo amor de deus vai
conhecer e aproveitar para o mercadão
para um sanduba de demonstrar é que
também é muito bom
ele estava apoiando a gente a gente
estava com o facão na mão só precisava
de dinheiro
um ano capitano acho que a gente entrou
em contato com 87 empresas 87 empresas
que a gente levou gastamos dinheiro do
próprio bolso para fazer um protótipo e
nada até que assim aos 47 do segundo
tempo conseguimos dois investimentos da
ambev da então e deu um mínimo para
conseguir dinheiro para fazer
foi o suficiente pra gente falar tudo
bem a gente tem um quinto do que a gente
precisava fazer o que a gente queria mas
a gente brasileira dá um jeitinho a
gente vai lá e fizemos
passamos o ano passado inteiro
desenvolvendo no brasil e lançou no
começo desse ano é o maior sala de
exposição de real de realidade virtual
de alta performance do mundo são 25
cadeiras
lá no catavento cultural exposição
permanente tudo científicamente preciso
feito com palha artista com para o
botânico falou o teólogo sempre brigando
com a gente porque a gente queria por
grama né
aí ele falou grama um dia na pré
história é tão bonito
jogamos tudo fora e que tinha samambaia
então este samba começa amanhã em todo
lugar e saber qual que foi a principal
decisão que a gente teve esse projeto
quando a gente faz um projeto dessa
magnitude
a gente queria fazer imóvel a gente
queria levar ele para as escolas
eu fico pensando se não tivesse tido
contato que eu tive com os computadores
se não tivesse tido o contato que eu
tive com a tecnologia
talvez eu nunca tinha seguido o caminho
a seguir
e nunca tá vendo a gente tem essa
oportunidade está mostrando esse projeto
essa tecnologia brasileira para milhares
de crianças e crianças muitas vezes
carentes e tudo o que a gente precisa
para mudar a vida de uma pessoa é um
estalo ela acreditar que ela pode fazer
alguma coisa e isso acho que é mais
importante a gente nunca pode duvidar
não importa o quanto os outros digam que
olha isso não é bem uma coisa que vai
dar dinheiro
olha isso aqui a gente não faz no brasil
você tem que acreditar e se uma pessoa
foi impactada por o genus do brasil ou
por qualquer outro projeto que já tenha
feito
acho que isso é mais importante
coisa que tem no nosso nossa vida no
nosso trabalho é influenciar os outros
influenciar os outros a serem melhores
influenciar os outros a seguir os seus
sonhos
obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]